national attention was drawn to just how
powerless the residents of washington dc
are
when the city's mayor was unable to
mobilize the national guard during the
capitol hill riot in january and
subsequently when they had
no say as sections of their city were
fenced off
the polls now show unprecedented
nationwide support for dc statehood and
activists feel this is their moment the
fight
for statehood is much bigger than the
the fencing
and the national guard you see but it is
really about
700 000 plus american citizens who
pay full taxes to this democracy who uh
represented it in the military that we
see uh but don't get
representation the u.s constitution
decreed that the us's capital was to be
hosted
not in a state but in a federal district
that would be controlled by
congress and have no voting
representation
but today washington dc has a larger
population than the states of
wyoming or vermont and pays more in
federal taxes
than 22 states nonetheless republicans
still argue
that dc citizens aren't worthy of
representation
wyoming is a well-rounded working-class
state
a new state of washington would not be
rama wright owns a small business in dc
for her it's pretty clear what cotton is
saying wyoming
is 93 percent white if washington became
a state
it would be the only state in the nation
with a plurality of black residents
i'm a real person the people that i know
in dc are real people
we are not only real people but we are a
very diverse city
we're one of the most diverse cities in
the entire country i think that there
is a very real effort
to squelch the voices of people of color
last year the house of representatives
overwhelmingly voted to make dc
a state for the first time a similar
bill has now been introduced in the
senate where the democrats have a
majority
but with a republican party fearful of
the creation of a state from a heavily
democratic city
it's not expected that the senate bill
will reach the 60 votes needed
to overcome a filibuster a parliamentary
tactic
the minority party can use to prevent a
vote
there is a way forward though if you can
bypass the filibuster
to affirm their supreme court justice
system you should be able to do the same
for
american citizens for democracy um
and that's what 51-51 is all about is
making dc the 51st state with bypassing
the filibuster and
passing dc statehood with the simple
majority
and in fact activists from 51 for 51
managed to get joe biden to support
waving the filibuster for a vote on dc
statehood while he was on the campaign
trail
absolutely i have for the last 28 years
51 votes in the senate
yes now that he's become president joe
biden's position
on bypassing the filibuster forward dc
stated has become a little less clear
but progressives think that biden has
already proven he can be pushed to the
left
especially when it's pointed out that
when republicans held all three branches
of government
they pursued their agenda ruthlessly
it's all
a matter of will she habritancy al
jazeera washington